شهد الشهر الماضي إطلاق PGA Tour
2K 23. هذه الخطوة تشير إلى عودة Tiger Woods
إلى غلاف إحدى الألعاب الكبرى
لأول مرة منذ عام 2014.
[موسيقى]
Edgar Woods هو واحد ولا توجد
طريقة أخرى حقًا لوضعها مرحبًا
لم يستطع العالم الحصول على ما يكفي من النجم الأمريكي الشاب
في التسعينيات من وجهة نظر تسويقية ،
فقد كان من الصعب حقًا أن يتردد صداها مع
التركيبة السكانية الأصغر
سنًا الذين كانوا يشترون ألعاب Sega Genesis
Sega Saturn وألعاب Super Nintendo
وهكذا  لقد رأى EA نوعًا ما أن
سلسلة جولة PGA نعم لديهم الترخيص ، نعم
لقد اخترعوا التأرجح بثلاث نقرات ،
فلماذا لم تتمكن سلسلة الجولف من
الانطلاق تمامًا ، احتاجوا
إلى محفز لجعل هذا الأمر برمته
ينفجر وهكذا  هذا هو المكان الذي
يأتي فيه تأييد النمر في EA Sports
في لعبة Tiger Woods PGA Tour 2004.
خاصة الألعاب الرياضية ، فهي تعتمد بشكل كبير
على كون تايجر وودز جزءًا
من المحادثة لكي يرغب الناس فعلاً
في ذلك.  العب هذه اللعبة مقابل تلك
التي لا يؤيدها لقد كنت مع
EA Sports لمدة أربع سنوات ولكني
ألعب ألعاب الفيديو منذ أه منذ أن كان عمري
حوالي سبع سنوات ،
كان Tiger Woods لاعبًا وكان
مستثمرًا للغاية وأنا  أعتقد أن هذا
جزء مما يميزه باعتباره رياضيًا رئيسيًا
ونجمًا في لعبته هو
أنه يعرف ما تطلبه شهيته من
معرفة ما سيبحث عنه هو نفسه
، ولهذا السبب كانت مساهمته الإبداعية كبيرة
جدًا مقابل ربما رياضي أكبر سنًا.
الذين لم يكبروا بالضرورة وهم
يلعبون الكثير من الألعاب ، أنا
فخور جدًا بما نحاول ونفعله
ومحاولة منح جميع اللاعبين هناك
شيئًا واقعيًا حقيقيًا ، فأنت تعرف
شيئًا يشبه في الأساس
الخروج في جولة للحصول على القدرة  لاختيار
عقله والعمل مع فرقه للحصول على
تعليقات حول أي شيء من
تنظيم القائمة إلى أنواع الدورات التي
أردناها هناك إلى مجرد تعليقات عامة
حول نوع اتجاه
الرياضة وكيف
تتطور الأمور.  مورد رائع لدينا ونحن
محظوظون جدًا لأن
الإصدارات الأولى من امتياز تايجر وودز
تضمنت مقطعًا صوتيًا لموسيقى الهيب هوب
اخترق اتفاقية الجولف
وأضفى عاملاً رائعًا على الرياضة ،
إنه أمر مضحك للغاية لأنني أعتقد الآن أنه
مثل  كثيرًا ما يشارك مقطعًا فيروسيًا
لافتتاح لعبة 2004 التي
تتميز بحفل DMX ، من المضحك
أن ننظر إلى الوراء ولكن في ذلك الوقت كان الأمر
كما لو كان هذا رائعًا للجولف ، وهو أمر رائع
للأشخاص الذين يلعبون ألعاب الفيديو الرياضية ، فهم
يميلون إلى الانحراف في سن أصغر بكثير لأنهم  إنه لأمر
ممتع أن يفعلوا ، فهم يعرفون كيفية رمي
الكرة وهم يعرفون كيفية لعب الجولف
قليلاً ولكنك تعرف ما هو أسهل في القيام
بذلك في إعداد وحدة التحكم
بشكل صحيح وتشغيلها هناك كما أعتقد في
مرحلة ما والتي تبدأ في  يظهر في
العالم الحقيقي أيضًا حيث لا يقول الناس
أنك تعرف ، دعني أجرب هذا فقط